Salut à tous c'est Pêcheur De Trésors.
Aujourd'hui, on va pêcher à l'aimant
sous cette passerelle
qui a l'air plutôt ancienne
et plutôt prometteuse surtout.
Il est 14 h 15.
C'est précis,
donc idéal pour commencer la pêche à l'aimant.
Aujourd'hui, on va vous tenir au courant
de notre avancée et de l'heure qu'il est
A chaque fois qu'on change d'endroit
Ou qu'on fait des belles découvertes
Il est l'or
Vous avez attaqué à quelle heure ?
Exactement pareil. 14 h 15.
Maintenant, j'ai plus qu'une seule chose à dire
Aimant lancé !
Mais qu'est ce qu'ils ont ces deux là
avec leur montre ?
Vous demandez vous ? Sûrement,
vous l'avez compris.
Cette vidéo est réalisée en collaboration
avec la marque Holzkern
qui fabrique des montres
et bijoux en matériaux naturels.
Il y en a un petit peu pour tous les goûts
et les produits ont une réelle identité.
On vous ajoute leur site en description.
Première remontée d'aimant de Quentin.
Ce n'était pas très loin.
Quentin, tu me permets 30 secondes ?
L'idée aujourd'hui,
c'est de tester ces deux montres étanches
en conditions réelles,
celle de Jade et la mienne.
Et aussi de vous faire découvrir
cette superbe marque
autrichienne qui propose
des cadeaux de Noël originaux, de qualité
et respectueux de l'environnement.
Ils ont même un modèle de montre
en minerais de fer.
Et qui sait, peut être qu'un jour,
Ils en font d'autres
avec des parties de poteaux électriques repêchés
Dans le genre de celui
que Quentin vient de remonter avec style
Il n'y a pas un seul poteau électrique dans le coin
après avoir cherché la provenance
de cet embout de poteau électrique
qui venait certainement de très loin,
on s'est rendu compte que Quentin avait
un magnifique couteau en bois.
Oui, oui, il est magnifique.
C'est un couteau à champignons je crois
Il est beau
couteau en bois de marin avec une ancre
qu'on s'est empressé de restaurer
Puisque tout comme chez Holzkern,
on adore nous aussi travailler le bois.
La majorité de leurs montres et bijoux
contiennent différentes essences.
Un modèle en lead wood matcherait super bien
avec le manche de ce couteau.
Et pour la petite histoire,
il s'agit d'un couteau London
inspiré des couteaux traditionnels
de la marine anglaise.
En tout cas,
si vous voulez une jolie montre
comme chez moi
ou si vous voulez faire un cadeau de Noël,
vous avez la marque Holzkern
Déjà qui est super sympa avec nous
parce que c'est eux
qui ont sponsorisé cette vidéo
mais surtout qui est très qualitative
puisque la montre tient le coup.
J'ai fait attention de pas la rayer quand même
parce que je suis pas fou.
Vous avez le code promo FISHER15 qui
offre 15% sur toute la boutique.
Il font des montres,
mais il faut aussi des jolis bracelets.
On va vous les montrer,
Jade a eu un magnifique bracelet
en plus de sa montre
Ta montre c'est laquelle du coup ?
Beryline
Donc en véritable nacre
Oui sympa.
Je remonte d'abord
Attention au bord Quentin
C'est un fusil ?
Ah c'est un marteau
Stylé !
Il est trop beau.
Il a pu servir pendant la construction de la passerelle.
Il y a un moyen, mais il est stylé.
Il est ancien.
C'est le marteau de Thor.
Oui vraiment, il va avec la passerelle.
La preuve que ce n'est pas pêché ici
Ah oui, ça n'a jamais été fait.
Superbe et vraiment magnifique.
Magnifique !
Toi aussi ? C'est rempli.
Il y a une fourche
Il y a des outils anciens ici.
Super la fourche juste après la grosse masse.
Il y a tous les piques, elle es entière.
Ça s'annonce très bien.
Bon, premier lancer, première galère.
Il y a plusieurs choix.
Il y a plusieurs choix, soit
on va chercher le treuil dès le début.
Soit on essaye de le décoincer en tirant,
il est juste là.
On pourrait pas agir avec une perche,
avec un gros bois
Pour tirer de plus loin
C'est toi qui voulait aller dans l'eau aujourd'hui Jade
Tu as ton occasion parfaite
En plus c'est moi qui ai remonté l'aimant
C'est celui qui lance l'aimant qui compte pour aller le débloquer
Ouais mais...
C'est la règle.
Non, si tu fais exprès de le remonter n'importe où
Normalement quand tu jette un aimant, c'est toi qui le remonte
mais là, non
- Parce que c'était trop long.
Bon, on va pas commencer avec ça en début de vidéo
Tu vas dans l'eau, c'est le principal
C'est pas le principal ...
Tu nous diras si elle est fraîche.
Et ce sera l'occasion de tester
l'étanchéité de la montre Holzkern
Je compte sur vous, si elle ne fonctionne plus quand je remonte, on va supprimer ce rush
On ne fait pas exprès d'aller dans l'eau pour tester l'étanchéité
Il n'en a pas envie, je vous le garantie
Elle est froide !
Ah bah oui les températures ont baissées, on est en novembre,
Il y a peut être quelque chose de bien au bout
C'est en acier ?
Ouais
En fait, il est emmêlé
Bravo !
Aimant sauvé
Mais pas de trouvaille
On ne remonte plus vers là
L'étanchéité à l'air OK
D'après ce que j'ai vu sur le site,
je peux aller jusqu'à une trentaine de mètres.
Ça devrait aller.
J'espère ne pas devoir le faire aujourd'hui.
Non, on continue.
Jade a récupérée une barre
Elle n'était pas entièrement dans l'eau.
Ça, c'est sec.
Jusqu'ou ça va aller ?
OK, tu as désherbé un peu en même temps.
Peu beaucoup.
Remonte vite, tu vas te coincer sinon
Encore un outil, non ?
C'est des morceaux de pont
Ça, c'est des morceaux de la passerelle surement
Si vous savez ce que c'est commentaire
Sympa
Encore une grosse barre
On a amené la disqueuse
Encore une
Elle est aussi grande
J'ai attrapé un morceau de voiture.
Petite voiture.
Un essieu avec les deux roues.
Celui là n'est pas trop lourd pour une fois
C'est rempli, mais il y a trucs qui ne viennent pas
J'ai rien eu pour l'instant, depuis le début.
A part ce que vous n'avez pas rangé.
Qui c'est qui siffle et danse ?
C'est ScottyFive
Il ne l'a même pas reconnu !
C'est quoi ça ?
Oh Rasta !
Ça va ? Je ne suis pas un rosbif
Comment ca va ? Tu as prit du muscle
C'est quoi cette veste ?
Rasta ! Allé vient !
J'ai trouvé une paire de ciseaux.
Baptiste Qu'est ce qu'on fait avec ça ?
On te coupe les ongles des pieds mon petit Quentin
Exactement
ScottyFive vient de nous rejoindre et
il va assister en direct à la meilleure découverte de la journée
puisqu'elle est au bout de mon aimant.
Tu rêves ?
Ça tombe bien, voilà
C'est ???
Une magnifique visse de pont
Il est 14 h 45.
Ça fait une demi heure qu'on pêche
Une demi heure. Pour l'instant,
on a fait des vieux outils.
On espère faire une arme ancienne
parce que sur les spots comme ça, c'est
pas impossible.
Donc voilà,
et on va remonter l'aimant
Regarde ça.
Il est encore rempli.
Pour l'instant, c'est de la vieille
ferraille, j'ai l'impression.
Ouais, ouais.
Mais c'est bien ancien. Encore une fois.
On continue.
C'est bien là.
Ici, c'est bien
Il est pas méchant. On dit bonjour, on se renifle les fesses
Allez, Jade a quelque chose.
En général, elle pêche tous les bons
trucs
C'est énorme, tu l'as vu ?
Je viens juste de le voir, je ne te dirait pas ce que c'est
Il y a une barre qui monte ?
C'est pas ça
Une vélo !
C'est cool
Il est ancien
Aller Jade !
Quentin, tu lui donne un petit coup de main ?
Voilà, l'union fait la force.
Bravo ! Super vélo.
Les freins sont encore bons.
C'est bon je peux faire du vélo
Magnifique.
Sans chaîne tu ne vas pas aller loin
Quentin préfère les vélos sans selle mais sans chaîne c'est pas mal aussi
Alors, qu'est ce que c'est ça ?
Un bout ?
Oh, un hélicoptère.
Un hélicoptère ouais !
J'ai déjà trouvé un drone mais hélicoptère c'est une première
Je vois bien le titre de la vidéo, on pêche un hélicoptère.
Sympa.
Il y en a un qui a dû pleurer sous le pont
ScottyFive est venu avec 60 mètres de corde.
Peut être qu'il aura fini de dérouler
avant la fin de la journée.
Les gants de ski.
J'ai les gants de ski et toi tu as le veste
Oh le leurre de pêche ! Attend, c'est un leurre ?
Non, c'est une brosse à dent !
"Signale"
c'est une brosse à dent.
C'est une première aussi
Mais est aimantée ?
Il y a une barre en fer dans la brosse
à dent.
Ca va finir par payer ce spot
Une arme de la seconde Guerre mondiale.
Je vous l'annonce.
Je peux mettre mes clefs dans le sac ?
Ça dépend, tu as quoi comme voiture ?
Un Clio
Tu peux
Je ne dirait rien pour le shit qu'il y a dans la poche avant
C'est à Jade
C'est pour Rasta, c'est thérapeutique.
Il y a une hache je crois
Si il y a une hache
Le troisième outil
Elle est belle, elle est sympa.
C'est peut être une hache Gauloise
Tu peux la mettre dans notre collection
avec le marteau et la fourche.
Hop !
Sympa.
Ah ouais.
C'est le ferrailleur qui va être content de toi.
Regardez, en fouillant dans la rouille,
j'ai trouvé un petit boulet de canon
De mousquet
Je suis sûr à 100% que s'en est un
C'est cool, je garde.
Ouais, super joli.
Comme tu dis, on peut faire de vieilles armes
La lame de couteau.
C'est pas jeune.
Pour les problèmes à la molaire.
Mais oui, regardez,
il fait toutes les belles découvertes.
Superbe pince à dents
Pourquoi tu la goute ?
Je me suis mis un coup dans la dent
Elle est cassée.
C'est dégueulasse le goût
Un truc bien s'il vous plait !
OK, c'est une pelle en fait, ah non, même pas
Un leurre de pêche Marlboro
Trouvaille sympa
Ça, on dirait un pickup
Ah oui on dirait un morceau de voiture.
OK, bien joué.
Sympa ça,
C'est une vieille gourde, non ?
C'est bien vu Quentin.
Il s'agit en réalité d'une gourde de
la Première Guerre mondiale, modèle 1877.
Dans un sale état, certes,
mais une découverte historique
qui faisait partie de l'attirail des soldats
Oh ca bulle !
Qu'est ce que c'est ?
Un morceau de tonneau
Un tiroir
Pourquoi dans l'eau ?
Non, non, non, ça n'a pas de sens.
Je refuse de le croire.
Est-ce qu'il y a de l'argent dedans ?
Et non,
ça reste pas mal, bonne dépollution.
Bon, il est 15 h 30,
on est encore au même pont
Je viens de faire un sécateur,
donc encore des vieux outils ici
Donc là, c'est l'heure
à partir
de laquelle on commence à se demander
si ça vaut le coup de changer de spot
ou si c'est bien de continuer ici.
On n'était pas d'accord sur le sujet.
Moi, je suis plutôt d'avis de rester là
et d'essayer de trouver des objets anciens
et des peut être des armes anciennes.
Quentin voulait qu'on se rapproche
un peu plus d'une cité
Il y aurai potentiellement des objets
plus récents liés à la délinquance.
Pour l'instant, Quentin, c'est décalé là bas.
Scotty est toujours là
Mais on va continuer
On va voir si c'est plus judicieux
de rester là ou d'essayer de bouger.
15 h 40 Quentin m'a appelé
à la rescousse, il a besoin d'aide.
On est toujours resté à ce spot.
Un, deux, trois.
Un, deux, trois, ça arrive !
C'est quoi ?
Oh oui !
9mm où 45ACP ?
Dur à dire, je ne sais pas,
mais je sais que c'est une munition
Sympa, bien joué Jade
J'aime la tournure que prend cette journée
Belle trouvaille
Il est quelle heure après cette trouvaille ?
Il est 15 h 45.
Et elle est en quoi ta montre ?
En nacre, couleur or rosé
La mienne, elle est en bois.
Bois certifié allemand.
Qu'est ce qu'il va acheter
à sa douce pour Noël, Scotty ?
Une montre, un bracelet ?
Un bracelet
Non, non, non, ça non, c'est pas dans le contrat.
C'est une bonne idée de cadeau parce que jusqu'au 21,
ils arrivent à livrer les cadeaux de Noël
Ils garantissent que ça arrivera
avant le 24.
Vous avez aussi jusqu'au
15 Janvier pour les renvoyer.
Les retours sont gratuits.
Regarde l'avion
Qu'est ce qui fait ScottyFive ?
Ça vient pas,
il veut pas celui là
On essaie doucement ?
Doucement non
On a besoin de toi Scotty
L'aimant a bougé dessus
Il y a un truc
Enfin ! J'avais raison.
Bien joué
Super !
Il est beau et pliable.
Il sent bon
Fais attention tu as l'aimant encore accroché
Je vais chez Maison de la Détection
Et là, je tire la corde d'un coup sec
Ca serait drôle
Allé Rasta !
Il est beau,
La vase donne un style.
Une scie !
Une scie à bois
Scotty, c'est quel bois qui t'embêtait ?
Ca
C'est ça ?
Elle est morte en plus la branche
Elle marche
Elle fonctionne*
Oh !
Non !
J'avais une pièce aussi, 0,05€
Tiens
Merci
Tu iras d'acheter une sucette.
J'en suis ravie.
Alors, des indices
Je regarde tout ce qu'on a.
Ca c'est du briquet !
Il vient ?
Oui, c'est ça.
C'est une brouette !
Ouais, c'est une brouette
On a réussi à l'attraper un de chaque côté
Donc là, on l'a normalement.
Une brouette sans roue
Il manque un pied aussi
Elle va nous servir de bac,
On va faire comme un brancard,
on va la remplir avec tous nos trucs.
C'est un cadenas
Une mine ?
Mais non
Dommage
Je rigole, on ne trouve pas des mines comme ça,
c'est un cadenas récent
J'ai déjà vu ça quelque part
Je ne saurais pas trop dire
Ca ne serait pas un morceau de voiture ou quoi ?
Si, c'est possible
Une boule de pétanque !
Oui, représente le sud !
Plus que 5 à trouver et on pourra jouer
C'est bien une boule de Pétanque
Aucun risque,
tu peux le ramener à la maison.
Joli
On dirait un ciseau de tapissier.
Je vais avec Scotty, il fait de meilleures trouvailles là bas
Il y a plus de choses ici tu as raison
Quentin, venez vers là
J'ai un gros objet
Oh oui, ça vient
Encore de la grosse gouttière
Ce n'est pas le premier bout qu'on a trouvé
Dommage
Quentin, vas chercher un pistolet à billes.
Ca fait une cible ouais
Ça rigole pas
Au pire tu assommes un gars en jet ski
Ils doivent venir pour les jets ski
C'est sûr
Il arrive
Il faut lancer la herse
Ca mord ?
Un peu, tout ça va ouais
Beaucoup de ferraille ?
Oui, de la vieille surtout
Vous avez appelé la mairie ?
Non, on récupère tout, on a un utilitaire
On la vend au ferrailleur après
Vous avez attaqué à quelle heure ?
14 h 20
C'est précis, oui
C'est précis
La précision de nos nouvelles montres
a même été validée par les gendarmes.
Il y a quand même pas mal de choses
Vous n'avez pas trouvé de véhicule ?
Non, un vélo.
C'est vraiment des vieilleries.
S'il y a des tirs, des véhicules
volés, des armes, on vous appelle
Y'a pas de soucis.
Merci et bonne journée. - Egalement
Ils n'étaient pas là pour les jets ski alors ?
Non
Bizarre
Une boîte ! Ah juste une boîte à cigarette
On va ouvrir, on ne sait jamais.
Non
Un petit vilebrequin
Trouvé par notre ami ScottyFive encore
Sympa, c'est d'époque
Il vient d'une voiture tu crois ?
Oui je pense de cette taille
Il est assez gros, ça se rénove
Il y en a qui en font des cendriers
Oui, tu peux faire ça de la décoration avec
Attends, attends
Je crois qu'on pense à la même chose
Remonte le !
J'ai cru le voir
Je l'ai fait ! Je l'ai annoncé
Un fusil de chasse
Je sais que vous êtes
les pro de la restauration,
donc je vais vous le confier
Par contre, je veux juste que me fassiez
une photo une fois avant et après.
Ok avec plaisir
D'ailleurs je pense que
c'est aussi le moment d'en parler.
ScottyFive à sa chaine YouTube
Il est en train de relancer sa chaine
Tik Tok.
Difficile, mais.
Je ne sais pas
s'il pourra mettre ça sur Tiktok
Comment ça ?
Les armes ...
On vient de se rendre compte d'un truc
Le canon a été bétonné
Donc ils s'en sont débarrassés
pour qu'ils tombe pas entre de mauvaises mains
C'est une arme qui est devenue catégorisée à partir de certaines années
Regarde, il y a du béton à l'intérieur
Donc ils ont coulé du béton
Il est plus lourd alors, ah ouais quand même
Et donc bon, on va le restaurer pour qu'il soit beau.
Mais voilà, il sera jamais fonctionnel
et ce sera de la décoration.
En tout cas super découverte.
Ce qui est drôle, c'est que juste.
Il y a une demi heure, j'ai dit
avec Scotty, on trouve jamais d'armes.
Je te jure, on en parlé et tout
Il n'a pas désespéré et il a continué
En tout cas, vous avez la chaîne de Scotty en description de la vidéo.
Quentin, qu'est ce que tu en penses ?
Il est quelle heure ?
À quelle heure on a trouvé l'arme ?
Il est 16 h 37
On a fait la découverte au bout de 2 heures de pêche
Des fois, on passe des journées entières
ou on trouve deux ou trois outils.
On galère beaucoup et à la fin
de la journée, il n'y a plus de soleil.
On est en hiver
donc il y a plus du tout de soleil.
Et ça paye
La persévérance.
Surtout que tu voulais arrêter. - Oui.
Quentin voulait changer
d'endroit plusieurs fois
Au début, je pensais que c'était
une barre
Et surtout, que tu l'as lancé
une vingtaine de fois ici
avant de le remonter.
Trouvaille amplement mérité
Je compte sur vous
pour le restaurer.
Super
On a cru qu'il
y en avait un deuxième.
Ce n'est pas un canon ?
Moi aussi je veux une arme, comme ScottyFive
C'est nul ça
Pêche Jade, profite qu'on soit là
Allez, le troisième
Ah non.
Ça vient d'un moteur, ça.
C'est l'intérieur d'un moteur.
Ca fait son poids
Bien joué
Mais comme quoi tu fais un fusil
et des tonnes et des tonnes de déchets,
ça n'arrête pas.
J'ai lancé à une main !
Pas mal.
Oui !
Mais par contre je jette aussi loin à deux mains, il y a un problème
Oh Rasta
Il est sage aujourd'hui.
Oh attends, c'est sympa ça
Je sais ce que c'est.
C'est un petit étau
Sérieux ?
Ah bah oui, oui
C'est un outil que tu fixe sur une table quand tu veux
travailler pour bricoler ou autre.
Pour serrer quelque chose, pour le maintenir.
C'est cool, il est d'époque
Je n'y arrive pas !
Il faut y aller un par un.
Les objets pour les enlever.
Voilà,
ça, c'est un grappin
Fatiguée ?
C'est bientôt la fin, ne t'inquiètes pas
Il est restaurable, il est entier
17 h 33 C'est l'heure
de ranger la ferraille.
On a bien bossé.
Bien joué Scotty. Bien joué Quentin.
Merci et bonjour aux abonnés qui nous
rejoignent par hasard en fin de vidéo.
Et puis voilà Marcel Geoffrey !
Il entament une pêche
quand il commence à faire nuit
On revient demain matin à 6 h
pour la relève.
Ça vous va ?
C'est bon
Et comme d'habitude, bien sûr,
tout le résultat de notre pêche à l'aimant
va être vendu chez un ferrailleur
pour que ce soit recyclé.
On est dans une démarche de recherche de trésors
Mais aussi dans une démarche durable.
Un petit peu comme Holzkern,
le partenaire de cette vidéo.
Il font beaucoup de montre mais pas que
Jade a eu la chance de recevoir
un superbe bracelet pour Noël.
Celui là aussi est en bois naturel
Plutôt joli
Regardez le packaging, ça c'est les boîtes de nos montres
et du bracelet
en bois aussi, avec des aimants
très sympa.
Vous avez toutes les infos en description
de la vidéo et le code promo FISHER15
Qui vous offre 15% sur toute la boutique
Mais il faut le plier
Non pas besoin de plier
Elle l'a jeté dans la voiture même.
C'est carré, c'est posé